[Music]
i
loved what ronald moore did with
battlestar
and i know that you're working on that
as well and i'm sure that's a priority
project
for all the executives and everyone
involved um so can you provide for fans
of battlestar can you give an update as
to
the status of the the new the new battle
story the statuses we're still working
out the
uh working on the pilot um where you
know look it's a
big universe it's a big world i wanna
uh respect uh the ronald moore battles
battle star you know i i spoke to him
before i even took on the project
to make sure that it's all kosher with
him because the last thing i want to do
is step on his toes
and the one thing we both agreed on is
that it won't
be a reboot of what he did and um
which i i i think we both wanted and so
we're so we're basically it's sort of
still in the early phases of trying to
figure out
the world via the pilot um i think we've
got the basic construction
of the type of story we want to tell the
part of the mythology that we're going
to explore
because bellastore does have a rich
mythology and i i again i have to give
ron a lot of credit for that and um and
so now we're
sort of closing in on what the
first episode what that pilot's gonna
look like i'm curious with the network
um and are you is it one of these things
where you're
starting at the beginning thinking we
have a three-year plan a five-year plan
are you thinking about it
like in a finite way so you have like a
beginning middle and end
so mr robot was about one character
and and you know i've said this ad
nauseam in every interview i've always
initially thought of it as a film so i
had the luxury of knowing the ending
of mr robot and um and it was more
the the expansion of that into a series
feels easier than when you take a
concept like battle star which is
inherently
uh an ensemble cast of characters
where you're not telling just one story
but you're telling you're kind of
jumping into the lives of multiple
uh characters and they're and they're
and their arcs
and um and so there's a there's a bigger
sort of canvas that you're playing with
so um i think what we're doing is we're
we're going to work out
some of the construction of where uh
thematically and and sort of the
mythology of of of what
time span and what we're what type of
story within that time span within that
part of the mythology we're going to
tackle on
what we're going to explore in this
series but i don't
i don't know specifically and again
we're still early because we're only
talking about the pilot
i don't know specifically we're going to
work out every beat
of how it's going to end in the same way
that i did with mr robot it's a little
it's a little again very different
because uh of how personal and singular
mr robot was in its in its story too
many episodes can water down anything
so with um with battlestar you guys are
already thinking you want like an
eight-episode season a 10-episode season
something compact where it's like every
episode really drives
so this is something that's really
exciting i'm glad you asked this because
um
because i don't even know if it's out
there but when i spoke to peacock about
it
you know and mike leslie i should say
who's an amazing
writer he's he's he's the one that's uh
show running and writing the the pilot
uh the one thing we got excited by is
you know do we
do we release an episode a week do we
put them all
do we binge them all for for me it was
like
let's get in there and tell this right
story and it will tell
us how many episodes we may dump three
episodes in a row because it's a
three episode long battle you know
uh sequence that uh that needs to be
dropped in a row even though there are
three signifying chapters and maybe each
chapter is switching a different point
of view within that battle sequence
there may be a 20-minute episode that's
the backstory of one of the characters
that gets dropped right after that
so we're gonna really experiment with
form on this one
because battlestar again given the sort
of rich
uh mythology that's in there already we
want to hit
every nook and cranny and because of the
format because of peacock and streaming
and and and they've been so great such
great partners in us in
in trying to experiment we want to get
into the writer's room and let the story
tell us
how it wants to how it wants to be
released so i can't tell you the number
of episodes but it's
also kind of a little meaningless
because i think
we're going to look at it as a
sort of like as a as a as a sort of
spider web
where we can kind of plot and point and
say well this isn't chronologically
after episode one or two it's the
backstory of someone
but let's release that so that audiences
can check that out if they want
or they can jump right into the battle
sequence we're really going to try and
really experiment with with form in that
way and again i think
with a property like battlestar it lends
to that i i would imagine that you are
being offered well i mean look we have
you have your abc pilot you have you're
being offered a lot of different stuff
right now
um and i'm just curious do you envision
yourself being the showrunner of
battlestar or are you sort of
envisioning
setting it up doing the pilot getting it
off the ground and then bringing someone
on to do like the day-to-day while you
executive produce mike is writing the
pilot and he would be the showrunner and
um and i would i would just produce um
the thing is i'm a huge fan
like i said the ron moore original i
felt like for me in terms of like
uh that specific sort of scythe hard
heart
it's pretty hard sci-fi you know what i
mean it's um
it's it's a it's a it's probably a level
one too deep
for me and i didn't i didn't think i'd
be the perfect candidate
um but i know what i like about battle
star so that's why i think i
would be better more as an ep role on
this show and
again mike who's tackling it is doing a
fantastic job so he'll he'll be the show
could the pilot be shot later this year
or do you envision this more as like a
2022
thing i want to shoot later this year
again
a lot of that is up in the air given
uh kovid um and
uh and you know and just the sort of uh
the lay of the land in terms of
where the world is and where where we
can't even shoot it the other thing is
is that this is going to require
a big sort of uh production to to
start just to even start up production
and build the sets and
start getting the the vfx fine tune
because you know one of the things that
i always attribute
the ron moore battle star with is is the
the the vfx is just outstanding and
pretty revolutionary
i mean the shaky hand shaky cam in space
and the with the zooms uh that was very
raw and gritty that was
not something i had really seen in
sci-fi before
before uh battle star so we we sort of
have
our challenges when it comes to well how
are we going to
how are we going to take the mantle and
like and kick it up a notch with our our
balsar
so all with all those things in mind it
will be
um it will be tough to get it off the
ground this year but that's my goal i
mean i'm pretty impatient
again like i said i'm a fan of the show
so i want to see it as soon as possible
so i'm gonna i'm gonna push i'm gonna
push for 21.